yeah how's everyone doing last talk
right one more is there okay well if you
need to get up stretch walk around in
the back that's all fine I do that all
the time helps me pay attention it's
gonna be pretty casual here unlike the
previous presenters you like working for
these like famous projects and these
super polished applications I kind of
hacked us together myself and so this is
very much like the DIY project but it's
what the themes are very similar to what
we've been talking about this whole
afternoon I think we could have probably
renamed this part of the track like the
wrappers around JavaScript track or
something like that right see how many
of you guys love the capabilities of
JavaScript when it comes to making
visualizations in general it's awesome
how many of you guys like writing the
JavaScript code yeah exactly
right so that's like Python developers
we kind of sit in our chairs and we're
like yeah I want that I want that from
JavaScript and I want to make web
applications too and then I want data in
Python objects I want you know very
demanding I think we can be but the
result is you know that you have this
great synergy of like all these
different technologies and you get to
like put them all in one project and
deploy it and I kind of carry it from
beginning to end and that's kind of what
I want to show I want to show this idea
that I had to look to use API data from
the Washington Metropolitan Area Transit
Authority as well as Walk Score and kind
of like incorporate that with maps and
make a little application that helps us
visualize a city a little bit
differently all of this stuff is on a
github repository it's up here hopefully
you can see the address so you can
follow along there are a couple things
you won't be able to do until you get an
API key but
there are for example for Romana they
have a guest API key so if you just want
to play around with this tonight you can
just go copy this from their website and
hit their API with it that's obviously
gonna rate limit you if you try too hard
but but yeah so the what I want you to
take away from this talk really depends
on what you're bringing to the table
okay so I'm gonna jump into detail into
a bunch of different things ranging from
flask deployment on Heroku which we just
heard a little bit about - geocoding -
Korra plus whatever if you have some
merit some expertise in these areas feel
free to you know focus in on that
otherwise just pay attention to the big
picture and like how we're trying to
like bring these ideas back into this
like main project that we're working on
so you can yeah so you can focus on the
details you can focus on the big picture
you can focus on both can focus on
neither and just enjoy the pretty
pictures I enjoy doing that too
sometimes also cool so I think we're
ready at this point to jump in
yeah so all the basic boilerplate out of
the way
you know package management get Jupiter
I think we can skip all that stuff how
many of you guys think maps are art
that's a pretty high percentage yeah I
often think about maps and you know this
whether there is a distinction between
art and like practical visualization in
some sense maps can be like data frames
just like like pandas but indexed by
latitude and longitude and then a whole
bunch of features right but they really
allow for a lot more abstract thinking I
think than just looking at a data frame
this is a map of what do you guys thinks
is a map of
it's actually a map of submarine cable
like the underwater fiber-optic and
other kinds of cables that carry data
all around the world is it these people
actually put out this really cool
comparison chart between a map like this
and trade route maps from like centuries
ago and you can like notice the
similarities and differences so I look
at something like this and I'm like yeah
this is it's showing me data but it's
showing it in a way that like
immediately brings up all of these other
contexts right context of history
contexts of geography context of the
world you can see like just by looking
at where these cables are you can kind
of get a sense of like where people are
so I think obviously maps are very
powerful I probably don't have to spend
any more time convincing you guys of
that so so let's just jump into how we
can like make maps that are as beautiful
as I think this is in Python and so the
answer is going to be like everything
else a wrapper and we are going to wrap
a JavaScript mapping library called
leaflet I'm just going to run all the
things here it's my favorite button in
Jupiter restart kernel and run all the
Python JavaScript libraries called
leaflet and if you've been like looking
at these other talks like how do they
deal with these cool sliders and widgets
and they click on stuff and things
happen all of that is JavaScript right
javascript is this engine that connects
what the user is doing in a web browser
to some back-end
logic and can instantly communicate
between the two so that you don't have
to like refresh a web page to get a new
map or a new visualization just
instantly updates and so if you look in
the leaflet documentation you know
you'll see things like ok here are
events and it's like listening for
somebody to move the map and it's it's
gonna trigger some action when somebody
stops zooming or something like that
right these are all the
ways that we can like get interact
interactivity into our into our apps and
JavaScript and so we're going to have
that same interactivity in in the Python
version I'm going to split this up into
a few little mini projects just to
prevent this from being too overwhelming
so the first thing we're gonna do is
just look at some basic bus tracking I'm
going to skip through some of this
there's some exercises in this notebook
and stuff like that you can try at home
so when I say bus tracking I mean I want
something that will show me a map of
where buses are in DC right now that's
what I want so the inputs are some
location of interests and some search
radius around that location is also
helpful for like limiting the scope of
this and our output is like the location
and information about the buses in that
area so the first thing we're going to
need to do and this is the first of
those little subtopics I talked about at
the beginning is something called
geocoding geocoding I like to think of
it as I don't actually know what it's
short for it but I think of it as like
geographical information encoding right
I want the geographic information
encoding of a thing right so if I have a
location if I have some place like Union
Station in DC I want to ask I want to be
able to ask a geo coder what is the
geographic information associated with
Union Station and it should spit me back
something like this this is the address
of Union Station this is the city this
is how confident I am about this being
right country icon some of the most
important to probably latitude longitude
for doing mapping another night things
like neighborhood right place ID postal
code a whole bunch of stuff so where
does all this information come from
yes yeah well they probably have their
own geo coder at the geographic
Intelligence Agency there are a lot of
different geocoding providers okay
google has one they don't I think you
kind of don't can't get it for free
anymore
this is the OpenStreetMap geo coder it's
osm this geo coder package which is a
python library i imported at the top is
just a something which makes it easier
to manage the request to and from these
geo coders so a geo coder osm is a
shortcut for a whole bunch of like HTTP
requests to and from the OpenStreetMap
urls this is a nice kind of convenience
function so this data is is only as good
as Open Street Map is and actually the
Google geo coder is a lot better at like
figuring out what you mean by these
location strings like I can type in the
Google geo coder you know Capital One
headquarters and it will probably figure
out that it I'm talking about this
building but if I try to type that into
the Open Street Map geo coder it might
be like sorry I couldn't really figure
out what address you're trying to talk
about and we'll might see an example of
that later in the app with almost
certainly will because I'm sure it won't
work so we have all this information now
right we've got all of these fields now
and the idea is like now let's make a
map in folium maps are hierarchical
objects okay you make a map object and
then you add things on to that object
you can think of it as like you make a
canvas and then you're going to like put
things on to that canvas so all I'm
gonna do here is I'm gonna make an
object called bus map and it's a folium
map I'm gonna initialize it with a
location which is the latitude and
longitude that I just got from the geo
coder and I'm gonna start it at a
certain zoom because otherwise you might
end up looking at like the earth or like
a block and then I'm going to add a
child to that map which is a folium
marker all of these capital map marker
these are folium imported from folium
and the marker also has a location but I
also can give it pop-up text and I can
make give it a custom icon it can color
that icon and then I'm just going to
type bus map and Jupiter notebook and
I'm gonna see a map like this I really
should not scroll using the touchpad on
something like this this is what I see
this is Union Station in DC right and
I've got a little pop-up marker here
saying okay here's the address
so it's not magic but it is kind of nice
because this map is scrollable and I can
go however far I want here I can even go
all the way to Capital One headquarters
if I could find it I know my Virginian
geography which I don't here
so we are like right around there and if
I wanted to go look at other countries I
could I could just keep scrolling I
could do whatever I want in this map I
can zoom out I can zoom in and so this
is kind of like the benefit of tapping
into that leaflet interactivity right
because this is JavaScript I can
actually update this in the back or
update this on the notebook and the
information is like dynamically being
retrieved from the Internet and in the
background and you'll notice like there
were some people talking today about
like tiles you can see these tiles
loading on the edges right it's
dynamically updating that so so that's
pretty cool and the other nice thing is
that this is in a notebook right so
how's this in a notebook well it's
because folium is it's really just
spitting out HTML right in the notebooks
can handle HTML they can render HTML and
so this is basically just a big blob of
HTML code which is largely JavaScript to
be honest that you can basically embed
anywhere you can bet it in a notebook
you can embed it in a web site so that's
like the portable part of what I'm
trying to talk about and you know we
could look at what this looks like if
you're you know kind of masochistic and
you want to see what this is is no point
zooming in because it's it's worthless
but this all of this is like a map right
every one of these things is
representing like a polygon or a marker
or a tile or something like that that's
what I mean by like JavaScript blah but
I don't have to touch it I don't have to
write it I don't to maintain it I can
just enjoy the benefits ok so that
allows us to also save these files right
so I could save this as HTML I could
email this to somebody they would have
the same scrollable zoomable map with
the pop-ups with the text that comes up
when you click on it all of that stuff
would still be there so that's folium
the basics all right now let's talk
about pulling in some extra data and
essentially doing some joins on live API
data
for those who went to the web scraping
talks that there were on yesterday you
know you might have noticed that they
there were some really good talks about
like responsible scraping of the web
I have not built in these checks here so
this is like very much do not
necessarily copy this but the principles
are the same I'm gonna start up a
request session so request is just
pythons way of interacting with HTTP
requests and I'm going to point it to
the LaMotta API and I'll be nice and
I'll stop retrying after two times if
they don't respond and I'm going to you
know structure this request the way they
want right just go to their API site
it's very clear easy to use you can
figure out how they want the request to
be sent and you can you know put your
API key in the right place you can make
the right keys and values to get
something out but the nice thing to do
the really nice thing to do would be to
not have to make the same API call twice
for the same data like every time I run
this notebook why should I hit the
ramada API again for the same exact
information and so one of the things I
built into this project as I was kind of
like assembling the Frankenstein's
monster is some ability to cache API
calls right especially when an API is
free like you shouldn't be hitting that
more than you you really should
more than you really need to right it's
uh it's like the tragedy of the Commons
thing which was in the keynote from the
very first day right eventually
somebody's gonna be like alright well
too many people are using this abusing
this free API and we're gonna take it
away so edible pickle is one kind of way
that you can do this in Python there's
many ways to do it
edible pickle the way it works is it
literally puts a deck gives you a
decorator which you can wrap around your
functions and then the output of that
function will be pickled and cached in a
location that you specify and it's
cached based on the function inputs so
you can see that here I basically
templated arguments 0 1 & 2 for this
function which corresponds to latitude
longitude and radius and so it's going
to make file
like some latitude X some lauded
longitude underscore radius some number
dot bus lists as going to put them in a
cache directory and then edible pickle
when I run this function again it's
going to look in that directory and see
if there's a file that matches the
inputs that that function was just
called with and if there is it will just
load the pickle and pickle the result
and return that as opposed to executing
the function again so very simple kind
of memoization type stuff we can play
around this yourself by by adjusting
this keyword if you do refresh equals
true it forces it through recalculate
the function if you leave it false then
it will just get it from the cache
because this is cached I know that
there's going to be a bus heading to the
Kennedy Center on Massachusetts Avenue
this one that's been there every time I
run this demo notebook because I don't
need to hit their API over for the live
data right now and just an example of
what the JSON looks like from the the
API when you get the response from
Romagna probably will gloss over this in
the interest of time but you can see
that this get buses function I put in
the latitude longitude and radius and I
get back out a whole bunch of bus
objects and one of the bus objects might
look like this with a vehicle ID
location where it's headed whatever so
then all I'll do is I'll just sort of a
for loop and I'll add to the map every
bus that I found in this area right so
that's why I'm making these little
polygon markers and so I can see that
this is like you know different routes
of buses going different places so
pretty cool that's the bus tracker part
everyone okay with that how we like
pulled together this API and caching and
the map and all right not too bad not
too bad so let's do like aggregations
right that's what everyone has to do
next that's what you do in most data
analysis right let's a granade when
you're talking about
Maps aggregations sometimes well down to
drawing lines on those maps and thinking
about regions so how do we do that in
folium the motivation for this part is
really just like looking at some census
data census data is really nice clean
data set that has geographical
information and and properties about
each of these geographical areas so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to load a
Geo JSON file that I just found on the
internet geo JSON is a JSON that
describes a region so what does that
mean well it means that instead of
before or I had latitude longitude in
some information about that point now I
have a whole bunch of coordinates and
these coordinates taken together
basically draw out like a polygon right
each coordinate is like the vertex of
the perimeter of the polygon and so and
then I have some properties about that
that area and and it like what its
population is in general this population
is 709 so I have these four like every
neighborhood in DC that's what this geo
JSON file gives me so how do I map this
now well one thing I might want to do is
color these areas based on these
properties right let me assign a color
to each population so that if there's
higher population it's like a deeper
shade of green or something and so color
mapping is a kind of interesting
decision that you have to make when you
just when you do this color breuer
is one really nice way to think about
this probably not enough time to go into
the details of this whole process but
suffice it to say you can figure out
like some nice palates for the
information you have depending on
whether it's like sequential or
diverging or qualitative data it might
want to choose different colors
depending on how many classes you have
this is three for example if I crank
this up to nine you can see how their
palette interprets that and
where they make the breakpoints and
they're trying to do this - like
maximize legibility you can still kind
of see the difference between each of
these different classes and it just
looks cool you know it's better than
just like randomly assigning colors red
green blue yellow you know whatever so
we can like access this in our notebook
as well we import these linear color
maps and you know we can choose a linear
green blue scale a purple red scale
we'll scale them according to the
minimum and maximum of the population
and the poverty rate those two of the
attributes we have in the census and we
will then make a folium map we'll add a
little caption that shows a population
scale so that people are not so confused
and then we'll just call folium geo JSON
and put our JSON data in and basically
tell folium that we want to style this
region based on this lambda function and
so when we say fill color is this pop
color is this pop colors is our color
map and it's translating between the
number of the population and some color
hex right that's what this is showing up
here so what you get out of this after I
add some layer control which will just
give me a little bit of a be able to
click these layers on and off is
something that looks like this so I can
look at just population and so this is
the green blue range and you can see the
scale at the top which kind of shows
like population zero is kind of in green
five thousand is kind of in blue and you
can see all of the regions with dashed
lines that came from the Geo JSON the
tiles are different because you can
specify the file that the tile type in
folium so this is like a less colorful
map so that the colors are more evidence
when you when you color the regions
right you wouldn't necessarily want to
make these colored regions on the first
map that we had and the layer control
lets you click these layers on and off
so I can look at just the poverty rate
by region I can look at just the
population or I can overlay them
and then the cool thing about this is
you can kind of like over a blue overlay
blue and red and get a kind of
intersection type of query where you're
looking at like looking for purple
regions where the poverty rate is high
and the population is high right and so
then you can kind of like look at this
from a bird's eye view and get a a sense
of your your data but we can do so much
more because this is in Python right so
what if we want to make some custom
properties for these regions well just
let's open this up in pandas right let's
just take our pandas dataframe which we
made a little bit earlier we made a
pandas dataframe here
we cycled through all of these
neighborhoods and the Geo JSON and like
extracted out the properties and made a
panda's data frame of them and so down
here we can create a population density
variable now that like normalizes by the
area of the region and then we can
update the geo JSON so we go back into
that that geo JSON like massively nested
structure and add a property for density
to each one of these regions and then
remap it and then we'll see something
like this and you know if you go back
and compare these maps you'll notice
that like there's a lot less purple over
over here east of the Anacostia and
south of the Anacostia because even
though there's quite a lot of population
out here the regions are bigger and so
the density is lower so like you can
think about different ways you can
structure these queries to get at the
exact kind of information you want and
you can use whatever processing you want
in Python to do that and then have that
reflected in the map
so it's everyone still with me yeah all
right yeah so this guy's kind of the
limit for this kind of thing one last
example in a couple minutes I'll show
you is Walk Score by this point in the
project I was kind of thinking you know
there are so many ways to to visualize
this right there's so many ways to like
look at what the city actually means
maybe I shouldn't limit myself to these
like political boundaries right that the
census gives you or that the city gives
you always see this diamond in DC you
know and so how can we visualize cities
in a different way this is just a side
note from the chloroplast stuff this is
something else you can do in folium as
well just add a slider that like cycles
through different values as time changes
and like link it to the time stamps so
that you can kind of scroll through time
and see how things change on your
choropleth pretty cool alright so
different ways of visualization you guys
seen this map before this is a map of
the US but the only thing being mapped
here are bodies of water right there's
no streets there's no state boundaries
there's no coastlines
it's just rivers lakes streams and so
what I'm thinking about this ain't along
the same lines with Walk Score this is
the The New York Times is uh they came
out with this recently it's like every
building in the u.s. right again there's
no streets on this map it's just
buildings this is Chicago I I used to
live in Chicago I love the the grid you
can kind of see I hope just how like
grid like it actually is
and you can also you know we can
actually go back to DC maybe
yeah it doesn't matter but the point is
that like you know we're mapping the
city not based on what we think the city
boundaries should be but based on what
the elements of the map are saying right
so when you think about Walk Score Walk
Score is this product that tells you
like wherever you are how walkable is
that region like are you close to stuff
is it easy for you to get around be
close to transit you close the grocery
stores things like that so what if we
mapped this whole like what if we mapped
our city based on what the Walk Score
was for any given area as opposed to the
boundary of the city itself and
furthermore what if we filtered that
based on like bus routes right so this
last example is basically taking LaMotta
API information about what routes buses
take and coloring it by what the Walk
Score is for every stop along that route
not every stop sorry for every
continuous location along that route
it's not exactly continuous but there's
a lot of data points and so what you end
up with I don't necessarily think I need
to go into the details because it's very
similar right we're just going to define
a different kind of API query to LaMotta
define the the request to Walk Score
make sure that we cache everything and
then like all the magic happens you know
here you can see that we're like kind of
iterating through all the pins that we
get and getting the Walk Score for each
pin and then some other boilerplate
stuff and then what we'll get out is
this part where we can just select a
route and get the rap scores for that
route and hopefully we get something
like this like a series of latitudes and
longitudes and what the Walk Score is
for each one and then we can use folium
color line to actually go and take
straight from our pandas dataframe a
certain column and treat each one of
those column entries as lat/long points
on a line to be plotted and what you get
out of that is something like something
like this where I've added the
population back in but you know that's
toggleable and so this is like route l2
in DC the
goes from Friendship Heights down to
Farragut square by the white house and
so you can see the Walk Score like all
along that route and you can see like
we're in this city is not very walkable
where is walkable and where did the
buses go so like there's an exercise in
this notebook after this you can cycle
through a bunch of the routes you can
look up the routes that go over the
Anacostia River to South East and see
you can maybe even categorize these bus
routes by looking at these walk scores
as are they bus routes that connect
places where people are already close to
stuff or they places that are like
taking people in and out of areas that
are not walkable right like is this a
bus that's meant to get people out into
and out of a zone that doesn't have a
lot of stuff or is it just like a way to
carry people around on their way to work
and you can imagine you can make heat
maps using this you could do anything
anything you felt like with this data so
that's basically what's in this notebook
the yeah so does that make sense
cool yeah it's pretty straightforward
and it's not it's not it's a little bit
more hack together than like using
something like - which would be really
awesome but I just wanted to show how
easy it is and how much power you
actually have in Python to go and pull
all this stuff from all these really
cool data sources and libraries and
technologies out there and just kind of
like mush it together and make a product
so the last thing I'll say and I'll stop
for questions because it's been half an
hour is this is a product so because
this is in Python we can deploy this on
Heroku Heroku is just what are the last
remaining free hosting services they
actually have this thing where they can
they'll spin up your application only
when people visit the site right so if I
want to go look at this Apple
ocation online I be being my best
interest to refresh this page to make
sure the application is actually alive
right now and so what I did is I took
the bus tracker part of this and put a
front end on it that asked people for
the location and the radius part of the
equation and then the application reads
that from the form
it makes the API call in the background
it makes the folium map the folium map
is just JavaScript so then flask can
just go ahead and render that JavaScript
so what that looks like is if I want to
click on a low font Plaza search radius
and so there there it is and there's
these are actually live buses now going
to Dulles going to foggy bottom
partially that's because Heroku is not
very good at caching Roku's file system
is kind of ephemeral and read-only so
you can't like save stuff on Heroku file
system and expect it to be there after
the flask request context is stopped so
that means caching is trickier you have
to like save stuff on s3 or you have to
like figure out other solutions but
because I figured nobody will really
ever use this app I'm kind of okay but
yeah and we can you know after this talk
is over if you're interested in the code
the code is all on the github like I
said there's two parts to us the demo is
what I walk through the notebook and the
tracker is the flask application and
yeah so I'm happy to take any questions
about any of this
see if we can get it to break
it's Sunday people what what is going on
here yeah so let's put in the location
we know won't work like maybe the
National Zoo
I don't think OpenStreetMap will be able
to parse National Zoo to an actual
address so it hits the the geo coder
error page yeah so so how granular can
you get with like the shapes when you're
like not at the state level but you're
like maybe on the neighborhood level and
yeah that's that's kind of one of the
challenging parts about working with
this kind of data is that you need the
shapes right I it would be extremely
painstaking to go and like look up
latitudes and longitudes for some custom
shape that you want it to draw around
your house or something like that right
so often we rely on shape files from
authoritative sources that so like the
census data that I showed you they also
provide they they have like certain
shape files for different regions like
they have they have voting districts
they have other kind of like political
boundaries and you can kind of like get
these shape files and use tools like
there's some mention in the notebook but
you can use these tools to like convert
them to geo JSON and you can like make
it to that that you can use those shapes
in Python essentially and there's a lot
of like G is related Python tools that
will help you do that but you basically
need to find that file it's like ah
these neighborhood boundaries that I
showed you it's because I found somebody
who had gone to the trouble of like
making a shapefile for neighborhoods but
that's the only limit you can go as
granular as you want
have you ever tried to put colored
points or yeah so I showed you a few of
the things which I ended up thinking
worth look at the best but you know
folium has a lot of different options
for for putting markers on maps for
making heat maps for making shapes on
maps all sorts of stuff and it's
extremely customizable because it's just
hitting the leaflet API so anything
leaflet can do you can do info Liam also
and I just happen to think certain
things are cooler than others so I
wanted to do them but yeah you can do
all sorts of stuff yeah so I I haven't
tried doing that but like you saw how we
used a custom color palette right so we
could just replace this color palette
with whatever palette not plot lib has
and did it to do yeah so something like
this and so like the way that this color
is getting on to the map is is through
collect color and fill color like these
are attributes of like some CSS style
probably somewhere deep in the guts of
this thing that it's like choosing what
color to make the regions and what color
to make the points and you can change
these to be programmatically set based
on whatever you want right so you can
have them be static you can have them be
dependent on some Python function can be
dependent on whatever matplotlib tells
you you can have them be dependent on
what the user inputs and then have the
user say I want the color scale to be
this and then it will redraw the map in
that way so all of that is is completely
customizable
[Applause]